- You look so sharp, man.
- Oh, you know.
- [Kelly] Yes.
(audience clapping and cheering)
Is this what Emmy winners look like?
Is that what's happening?
- Oh you know what.
I still have my Emmy glow,
I feel like, you know?.
- I love that.
- Yeah.
- Especially when it's
unexpected, you know.
- Yeah
You know, you go there,
of course I presented
the first award of the evening.
I had a little monologue.
So, you know, being a performer,
being someone who loves
what he does, you know,
I went out there and my mind is mainly on
how do we kick this show
off the best way possible.
I'm first up, I got to
do a little monologue.
I'm presenting the first award.
My mind is on making sure I do a good job
and making sure people have a great time.
- Yeah.
- You know, what they
brung me there to do.
Of course, I hate to say that
the Emmy was second place,
but the Emmy is a nomination.
I don't know if I won yet.
You know what I mean?
So my thing is, initially
the show's great.
I sat down in my seat,
watch the rest of the show.
Halfway through the show, my
buddy turns around and says,
did you write a speech in case you win?
I said, no, I did not.
(audience laughing)
- That's when I win things.
I'm not prepared.
- You're not prepared for it.
- Yeah, that's when it happens.
- That's when it happens.
- Just never be prepared.